Joe joins us now you got this TV thing
down Joe we're working on it you know
it's always a work in progress but I'm
feeling pretty good we've had some good
ones on Thursday night this year we had
the Seahawks game couple weeks ago which
was unbelievable the way it finished and
solidified me that right now Russell
Wilson is the MVP of the NFL thus far I
mentioned this with Tony Dungy I feel
like if you're not drafted in the first
round at that position it takes you
longer it takes longer for us to almost
anoint you as being worthy like dak
Prescott if he's a first-round draft
pick we probably don't look at him the
way we do is a third or fourth round
pick
Russell Wilson with a third-round pick
why is that well it's because of the
resource that you invest in that
position it's unlike any other position
on the field where there's only one
quarterback you can't say that about any
of the other important positions on the
field and so when you draft a guy in the
first round not only are you putting the
money resource the draft acree source
but you're putting a team of coaches and
support staff around that person to try
to get success because we know clearly
that's the most important position on
the football field and so when you put
so much into that first-round pick
you're going to give them more time to
develop and you're going to give them
more opportunities but when you have a
third-round pick like that you're not
always drafting them with the intent of
making them your franchise quarterback a
lot of times you're thinking well he
could be a backup or maybe we develop
them down the line and trade them like
some teams have done and so it's all
about how much you invest in that
position as a first round pick verses
later round draft yeah but like Gardner
Minshew
oh he's a cute little story Kyle Allen
yeah it's a nice little story we don't
we don't almost
we're not validating what they do
probably because Kyle Ellen's not
drafted and Gardner Minshew is a you
know a mid round draft pick here
yeah well it's because of why you get
drafted in the mid rounds it's because
you have some type of flaw in your game
that we saw in college whether it be
your decision making your arm strength
your accuracy whatever it is going
through that draft process they've
identified a flaw and so you have to
overcome that and prove that you can do
it at the NFL level because of whatever
that flaw is whereas
when you're a top pick you have some
type of talent where teams are looking
at saying wow
Patrick mahomes look at this arm this is
generational so we're ready to anoint
him because in our minds we are already
pre conceived to be able to see that he
could be great so it's just a matter of
overcoming some preconceived notions
that we have as fans as coaches as
evaluators in the NFL yeah I guess I got
sidetracked because I think Russell
Wilson's been doing this it's just taken
people longer to realize that he's been
doing this I I think he's been as
valuable to his team as anybody any
player in the last couple years so
you've got a chance see him up close and
personal yeah what did you see last
without it because being in Seattle for
whatever reason just because it's such
an East Coast dominant sport in football
and in sports in general Seattle they're
always playing the afternoon game
they're not on everybody's TV as much so
people don't realize how much Russell
Wilson does for this team because he's
not always the guy that's putting up 400
yards but he's always finding a way to
win and that's to me why he's the most
valuable he makes everybody around him
better and he finds a way to win he's
Joe Thomas former Cleveland Browns
all-pro tackle what did you see last
night and as far as what kind of
solutions would you have for the inept
officiating that we've seen inconsistent
officiating we've seen well I think
truthfully we need to eliminate instant
replay because right now the NFL is
selling this folly to its fans that we
have in Surrey play because we want to
get it right and we have all these
different camera angles in these games
and we can clearly see that calls are
not being made correctly and then we go
to instant replay and in our minds we've
been told by the NFL they're doing this
to get it right but then they're not
overturning calls anymore and so I think
what they need to do is go to sort of
ask I judge I'm not a big hockey fan but
my hockey friends tell me that that's
kind of what they do in the NHL
whereas let's just play the game let's
not have unnecessary stops for instant
replay unless the sky judge sees
something that needs to be overturned
that's egregious that's clear and
obvious like the standard is that
they've set with instant replay but the
thing that fans hate more than anything
is being told one thing and then having
another thing don't spit in my face and
tell me it's raining NFL
if you look at what happened with Trey
flowers last night do you have any
problem as a former offensive lineman
you know Bakhtiari sold it a little bit
but flowers did not get his hand in his
face but they called it in those were
too costly penalties well I think what's
happened this year specifically is the
NFL really has sold out their officials
because they've said there's going to be
a renewed emphasis on Holdings on hands
to the face on the line plays whereas
those were the type of plays that really
the in the NFL they would let the
offense and defensive line play they're
not going to call ticky tack hands to
the face ticky tack Holdings but for
some reason they decided they wanted to
tighten that up in the offseason and so
that was a point of emphasis and so I
think whereas in years past
those were the type of calls that when
it's happening at full speed it's really
difficult to tell if that hand is in the
neck is it on the shoulder pad is it in
the facemask and kind of going into that
minutia is difficult at full speed now
as fans as viewers we have the ability
to go back and watch it frame by frame
and slowly see that that tray flowers
did not have his hands in Bakhtiari face
but what I think the NFL needs to do is
kind of go back to maybe the old
standard on some of these judgment calls
and say you know what let's let them
play especially in these critical
moments of the game it's too important
to not screw it up and it's too
important let's just let them play
unless it's really obvious in that
situation then you can throw the flag
but to be under the microscope the way
NFL refs are right now and then have the
NFL continue to push for kind of
splitting hairs on these judgment calls
in my opinion is a bad way to do it what
do you think the Browns need to do if
you said one thing that they must do
that if they're going to have a
successful season would be one well they
need to improve their consistency and
discipline and I think those things go
hand in hand early on in the season it
was a matter of penalties now it's
mental mistakes it's turnovers and I
think a lot of that goes back to
discipline I think Freddie kitchens did
a great job in his press conference
talking about hey this is the reality of
our situation in our team right now we
have a lot of talent but we're playing
as a group we're not playing as a team
we're not playing discipline we're not
paying attention to the details that
need to be paid attention to and so this
is their bye week hopefully they're
going to be able to go back and
maybe re-emphasize those little small
details because in football it's a game
of a million little things and you put
all those things together and that's why
the Patriots are good year and in you're
out they take care of every single one
of those details because no detail is
too important to spend time on but also
it's I want to simplify things when
things go wrong then you come back to
basics and you simplify and it feels
like the Browns were not doing that they
were trying for the big play
you know Baker was trying to be a star
instead of letting it just happen
naturally Freddie kitchens wants to
prove that he can coach in the NFL
whether he can or not you got to get
Odell Beckham the ball and Jarvis Landry
the ball and it you know it's just too
much and I don't know if they're too far
down the road where you can say hey
let's just come back let's run the
football let's just establish you know
this offensive line isn't great for
Baker to be running back you know
running around there he's gonna get
sacked he's not gonna have time to throw
the big homerun ball to obj and Jarvis
Landry can you do that it's hard to
argue with what you're saying and I
think that's a function of the youth and
inexperience when you have a roster as
talented as the Browns but it's full of
youth and and they don't understand
sometimes that sometimes you just need
to take what the defense gives you you
don't have to go do something that's out
of what the flow of the offense is and
early on it was all about Baker trying
to force the ball to obj it was how do
we get obj as touches it was alright
let's go make plays let's go live up to
the hype and some of that you saw you
know with Freddie kitchens like you
mentioned he needs to prove to the NFL
that he deserves this job that he
deserves to be a great offensive
coordinator that he deserves to be
playing and/or coaching all these
talented players and I think that's
probably one thing we will see coming
out of this by week is hey guys let's go
back to basics a little bit let's focus
on the things that we've done
consistently well up until this point in
the season and what is that that's been
running the football with Nick Chubb
which sets up everything else with that
offense let's not be so concerned about
who's giving the ball on how much
because you know what when Nick Chubb is
running the football efficiently which
is something that they can do because
Nick job is a special player all of a
sudden OBJ's not getting as much
coverage as he was before and now we can
throw him the football now we can get
him involve
and then it's much easier when you have
a simplified offense to take care of
those details and to play consistently
good football and I think that's what
we'll see coming out of the bye week if
you could block for any quarterback now
it would it be
I would love to puck for Russell Wilson
like I mentioned earlier he makes
everybody on that team better Patrick
Holmes he would be a lot of fun too it's
hard it's hard to argue between those
two but I just feel like Russell Wilson
with his experience and his
decision-making not only in the pocket
but when he starts to run and his
ability to understand when it's time to
scramble and when it's time to scramble
and make an unbelievable throw and the
fact that he's playing flawless football
nearly completing almost 75% of his
passes throwing the ball down the field
and just finding a way to win I think it
would be fun to play with them because
as much fun as it is to have the
starwars offense in Kansas City and
score 40 or 50 points to me the exciting
thing about playing in the NFL is
finding a new way to win every week and
when you have a quarterback like Russell
Wilson that's exactly what he's doing
because you're never in a game where
you're saying okay it's over or we don't
have a chance you're always looking and
saying Russell Wilson is our guy we're
gonna win this game great to talk to you
Joe's safe travels to Denver and we
appreciate your time I appreciate it
thanks for having me on dance but let's
show Thomas NFL Network analyst for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on be our live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]